So I recently came across a story that I thought
was really wild, but also somewhat disturbing
and I wanted to share it with you.
It's about Johannes Kepler, but it's also
about his elderly mother Katharina, the birth
of science fiction, and our reluctance to
be open-minded.
Kepler was a great German astronomer from
the 17th century, his name pops up in plenty
of textbooks today, for his laws of planetary
motion.
He lived in an era where there was no clear
distinction between astronomy and astrology.
But there was a strong division between astronomy
and physics.
People thought that the planets moved by only
the hand of God, Kepler himself wrote plenty
of horoscopes, but he also became the first
person to combine the map of predicting eclipses
with a physical explanation.
He showed that the movements we can see can
be explained by physical forces.
At this time, pretty much everyone believed
incorrectly that the sun revolved around the
earth, and that the earth was the centre of
the universe.
It's a fair enough belief because that's what
it feels like.
So it's easy to see how an uneducated guess
might go wrong.
But Kepler was an astronomer, and he was starting
to realise that the evidence pointed towards
a very different conclusion, it pointed towards
the heliocentric model presented by Copernicus,
where the sun is at the centre of the solar
system, and we revolve around it.
Kepler was a university student when he learned
about the Copernican theory, and he even wrote
his dissertation about it, but the uni kept
it kind of hush.
Galileo later wrote to Kepler to confess that
he was also a believer in the Copernican model,
but he hadn't dared to stand up for it in
public yet, and he wouldn't for another 30
years.
You might have heard about how that ended
up for Galileo.
He was tried before the Catholic Church and
sentenced to spend the rest of his life under
house arrest.
It was in 1616, that an inquisition declared
heliocentrism to be foolish and absurd, and
to contradict the Holy Scripture, they decided
it was punishable by death.
At the same time as Galileo's trial, Kepler
was rushing to try and save his mother, who
was facing a trial of her own for an equally
if not more, hated crime, witchcraft.
But all of these events are somewhat connected
in an unexpected way.
Years earlier, in 1609, Kepler had finished
writing a book called Somnium, or The Dream,
it is often called one of if not the first
example of science fiction writing, because
of how much hard science it contained.
Before I take a look at the story, I would
like to quickly thank Audible for sponsoring
this video.
The story that I'm sharing today about Kepler
is one that I read about in the first chapter
of the book Figuring by Maria Popova.
It is one of the most poetic retellings of
scientific ideas and of the human search for
truth and meaning.
I've been listening to it on Audible, which
is nice because I can listen to it in bed
before I fall asleep.
Audible has a huge library of audiobooks,
but also podcasts, guided wellness programmes
and performances, pretty much anything spoken.
As a member, you get one credit every month
to redeem for any title that you get to keep
forever, but they also now have the Plus catalogue.
So even if you've spent your credits, there
are still thousands of titles included that
you can always download.
I'm happy to recommend Audible because it
is something that I use already in my daily
life, so it makes a lot of sense for me to
share it with you.
New members can always try Audible for free
for 30 days.
And as we're approaching Christmas, there
is also a limited time offer to save 60% on
your first three months, which works out only
$5.95 a month, you can get that by going to
audible.com/tibees or for those in the US
you can text tibees to 500 500.
So here's the story originally written in
Latin.
It starts with Kepler falling asleep, and
he has a dream in which he's reading a book.
In that book, we have the story of an Icelandic
boy called Duracotus.
He's 14 years old and his mother makes a living
selling mysterious bags of herbs with mystical
markings on them.
She sells them to ship captains for good luck.
One day Duracotus cuts open one of the bags
to see what's inside and spills the contents
out everywhere.
His mother is really angry with this because
it loses her money.
So instead she agrees to give her son to the
skipper in place of one of the bags, and they
take off together and sail to Norway.
On the ocean voyage Duracotus becomes seasick
and so the captain leaves him behind on land
with instructions to go and deliver something
to the astronomer Tycho Brahe.
Duracotus ends up becoming a student of the
astronomer and spends five years in his care
learning how to observe the heavens.
Take this drawing with a grain of salt because
this book was actually written before Galileo
pointed the first spyglass at the sky, and
before Kepler himself had ever looked through
a telescope.
After a few years Duracotus travels back to
Iceland to meet up with his mother, she's
happy to hear that he has studied astronomy
and reveals that she too possesses lots of
knowledge on this topic.
But then she reveals that the reason she has
this knowledge is because she is able to summon
up these spirits or daemons, which can move
her anywhere on Earth in an instant.
It turns out this doesn't just include the
Earth though because she summons one of her
favourite spirits to speak with them.
The spirit tells them that 50,000 miles up
in the Aether lies the island of Levania,
which is Earth's moon, the spirits are able
to take humans up to the moon in a journey
of four hours.
Apparently, the journey is a shock to humans,
so they are sedated with drugs for the trip.
The spirit describes a trip to the moon and
also talks a lot about the Earth, which is
called Volva.
The name is picked carefully to represent
revolution or revolving.
As for the inhabitants of the moon, they believe
that the Earth rotates around the moon.
Volva goes through the same phases that we
see the moon go through.
The moon Levania is also divided into two
hemispheres.
One is called Privolva, which never sees the
Earth, it is the side of the moon that is
always locked facing away from us.
And the other hemisphere is Subvolva, which
does see the Earth as their moon.
A lot of the book is then a very detailed
scientific description of how the Earth would
look from the moon, how eclipses would look,
the size and orbits of planets, and even some
descriptions of creatures that inhabit the
moon.
Now at the time this was written the idea
that the moon revolved around the Earth was
actually well known and noncontroversial.
Kepler is trying to suggest that perhaps our
own certainty about Earth's fixed position
in space with regards to the sun is just as
misguided as the lunar citizens belief that
the Earth revolves around them.
When you're standing on the moon, and the
ground feels firm and motionless beneath your
feet, and you see this pale blue dot of the
Earth rising and setting against your horizon,
you can really be convinced in something that's
not true.
The story was written 300 years before Edwin
Abbott's Flatland, and in that book, we are
exposed to creatures that live in one dimensional
and two dimensional spaces, and we see how
it is utterly impossible to convince them
that there exists a third dimension.
In Flatland, the reader is left questioning
whether there must be some obvious fourth
dimension, that we are also incapable of comprehending.
Kepler hoped that by seeing the absurdity
of the lunar people's belief that the moon
was at the centre of the universe, that we
ourselves would have the insight to question
whether that was true for us as well.
He wanted to gently expose more people to
Copernicus's theory of the solar system, but
he knew it would be too complex and abstract
to just present the scientific facts to a
largely scientifically illiterate public.
Instead, he knew that storytelling was an
amazing way to share science, that still remains
true today.
Kepler perhaps knew that "The universe is
made of stories, not atoms."
It's quite convoluted how Kepler presents
the events as being within a book within a
dream.
And it creates quite a lot of distance between
Kepler and what he's writing down.
Perhaps that is deliberate as a way to be
able to deny and say that these are not necessarily
things that he believes.
The old fashioned 'retweets are not endorsements'.
It was called The Dream, but the story was
supposed to awaken people to a new scientific
truth.
However, it turned out their society was in
a slumber too deep to be helped.
Sometime in 1611, the manuscript got leaked,
but the science and symbolism were lost on
the illiterate, superstitious and vengeful
villages of Kepler's hometown.
It was taken to be more of an autobiography
since there were a few facts hard to ignore.
It was well known that Kepler himself had
been an apprentice of Tycho Brahe and Kepler's
mother was a herb doctor, just like the mother
figure in the story.
So when their fictional mother character conjoined
up spirits to travel to the moon, that was
taken literally.
So apparently a local woman who was already
angry at Katharina over a private matter,
heard of the book and used it as ammunition
to convince 24 others in the town to testify
that Katharina was a witch.
These accounts were as random as a man dating
the onset of his disability to a night 10
years earlier when he had taken a single sip
from a cup at Katharina's house.
Kepler took on his mother's legal defence
and dedicated six years of his life to disproving
each of these allegations, using science to
point to natural causes behind each one.
But his mother was arrested and taken from
her home in the middle of the night.
The accounts I've read and say that the dream
wasn't presented as evidence at the trial,
but Kepler did hold himself at least partially
responsible for her fate having written it.
Katharina was imprisoned for 14 months and
threatened with torture but confessed nothing.
Eventually she was released but never recovered
and died not long after.
Kepler spent the rest of his life obsessively
annotating the dream with 223 footnotes, as
long as the story itself, his intention was
to dispel superstitious interpretations by
giving his exact scientific reasons for using
each symbol and metaphor.
He says in footnote number eight, "if any
of you have read this little book before,
you will understand what forebodings this
book brought me".
He says, "These words were taken up by senseless
spirits and finally burned forth into rumour,
blown up by ignorance and inexperience."
He takes particular care with describing the
spirits in the book, and in footnote 34 he
says that they are the spirits of science,
to whom the causes of things are known.
There are nine of them, metaphysics, physics,
ethics, astronomy, astrology, optics, music,
geometry and arithmetic.
He also talks about his ideas of gravity.
And keep in mind this is before Newton is
even born.
Footnote 66 says, "I define gravity as a power
similar to magnetic force and mutual attraction.
The force of this attraction is greater in
bodies close to each other, rather than in
those that are remote.
As a consequence, they rather resist separation
from one another when they are still close
to each other."
In the very next footnote, he demonstrates
an intuitive understanding of inertia.
Again, this is before Newton would pen it
down in one of his laws.
Kepler says "because bodies are heavy, they
resist motion."
Kepler tried to publish the dream in 1629,
but he ran out of money.
He travelled 100 kilometres on a horse to
repay debts and try to sell his assets to
finish printing the book.
But on his journey, he came down with an illness
and died in 1630.
The Dream was published in 1634 by Kepler's
son Ludwig.
For Kepler, it seems that his search for truth
came at a great personal cost.
The idea that the earth was not the centre
of the universe was the first major challenge
to our self-importance, and each challenge
since has faced similar resistance.
300 years later, we would use Kepler's laws
to calculate a trajectory to the moon and
land there, allowing Kepler's Dream to come
true.
Thanks for watching this video and thanks
to my Patreon supporters for making it possible.
A special shout out to today's Patron Cat
of the Day, Jojo.